we know that the bmr formulas are
i would say good but not great
they they do as good of a job as i think
you could reasonably expect them to do
so depending on the formula in question
and the population being studied the
typical error of these formulas is
anywhere between like maybe 150 calories
and like 400 calories but you know
mostly in like the 200 calorie per day
range so
if
if something tells you that your bmr is
1600 calories per day you can kind of
tack like a 200 plus or minus error
range on that and you know it it's
probably what did i say 1800 1600 i
think i said 16.
so whatever so if it says 1600
your bmr is probably
somewhere between 1400 and 1800
individual errors can certainly be
larger than that but in all probability
it's within that 400 calorie range 200
plus or minus uh which you know could be
more precise but given the estim the the
information being plugged into that
calculator um you know that's i i feel
like that's about as good as you could
reasonably hope for it to do
but then
the the next step of that process going
from a bmr estimate to a tdee estimate
is uh
that's more of a crap shoot so basically
there there are uh various sets of
activity multipliers that you can use
but
by far the most common one i see
is 1.2 if you're sedentary 1.375 if
you're lightly active
1.55 if you're moderately active
1.725 if you're very active and 1.9 if
you are extremely active like those are
the the qualitative uh categories
sedentary through extremely active and
uh those those numbers i gave is what
you would multiply your bmr by to
estimate your total daily energy
expenditure
uh and so
you
immediately run into one problem which
is just how do you classify yourself uh
and so the the descriptions for these
aren't very helpful like they tend to
not disambiguate
lifestyle versus like dedicated exercise
so for example the description for
sedentary is inactive job and very rare
or minimal exercise and so you know what
if you have an inactive job but you
exercise five days a week
you know it
it's it's hard to say or extremely
active hard daily exercise and other
regular physically demanding tasks so
what if you do hard daily exercise but
have a sedentary job you know so it's
it's hard to know which of these
categories you're supposed to fall in
and even beyond that uh this is this is
i think more subtle but even if everyone
did perfectly know
which one of those categories they fell
into
uh simply by by multiplying by kind of
bucketed activity factors you still
increase the estimation error for total
daily energy expenditure calculations so
you know let's say that you
um
you know let's say your total daily
energy expenditure is 1.45
times your basal metabolic rate so you
would fall in between lightly active and
moderately active and if you choose
either of those two multipliers that's
going to generate
somewhere around five percent additional
error just because those activity
factors are bucketed uh and so with all
of that information um
i was very curious like what
the relative accuracy of these tde
calculators actually were and like i
said i couldn't find any research on
that
but
we we know enough that we can we can
model it uh pretty well so that's what i
did in this article and that at least
for me personally was the part that i
found most interesting and the part that
i liked writing about the most um so you
can you can check out the article to see
my methodology uh and also i i linked a
spreadsheet that you can use to tinker
with my assumptions if you want to
generate different estimates uh but i i
you know tried to generate the most uh
the most justifiable set of assumptions
that i could uh in order to attempt to
quantitatively uh address this question
and uh so i i was interested in
basically how often does this process
generate
a total daily energy expenditure
estimate that is close enough to your
actual total daily energy expenditure
that from the jump
calorie targets that you generate using
this approach will get you
pretty close to the desired rate of
weight gain or weight loss you want
and
basically what i found is that it works
about half the time
so
for
about for a little less than 50 percent
of people the total error generated by
this approach
is less than 250 calories per day so you
know if you're
actually burning 3000 calories per day
uh you know maybe a calculator will say
32.50 maybe it'll say 27.50 but that's
in the right general ballpark if you're
trying to lose a pound a week you'll end
up losing half a pound to a pound and a
half per week like doing a pretty good
job
but for
the other approximately half of people
it's it's generating relatively
inappropriate calorie targets uh which
can for a very small minority of people
be in excess of a thousand calories per
day which could mean if you're trying to
lose a pound per week you're actually
gaining a pound per week which or losing
three pounds per week and in a huge
deficit um
the the most
common kind of category of error was
between 250 and 500 calories per day
which would essentially mean that
if you were trying to lose a pound a
week you would be losing close to two
pounds per week or losing weight at a
essentially glacial pace like that that
was
about a third of people have errors on
that magnitude so essentially this
process is
it does a decent job of getting you in
the right general ballpark to start with
um
but you'll you'll definitely need to
make adjustments probably from the jump
for most people and certainly over time
as a metabolic adaptation kicks in um
and so then at the end full disclosure
there is a little macro factor pitch uh
you know essentially
once you have all of that information
you can make adjustments yourself you
know based on your your rate of progress
whether or not you're plateauing or you
can use a software that that will do all
of that for you